hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in his article the ethical significance
of course benefit analysis in business
and the professions Robert Audi starts
out by looking at utilitarianism briefly
which is a very important moral theory
used in General application whether in
ethics very broadly personal life
business medicine as he points out but
there are some problems that one could
raise in trying to use a cost-benefit
approach that is so Central to
utilitarianism and the first three that
he points out
stem from him you know raising an issue
can ethics really be this simple and he
says it would be tempting to answer yes
but this would be misleading because
ethics really isn't this simple if we
want to do ethics well we can't just get
some nice formulas and then go to town
and throw everything in there we wanted
to make sense and apply to the
complexities of real life or else it's
not much good
so cost benefit analysis based ethics
really can't be that simple and there's
more issues that could be raised than
just these three questions that Audi is
bringing up but these are pretty Central
if the goal is to quantify utility for
each person potentially involved or
affected by the options that we're
looking at and then thinking about the
probabilities right so if we're going to
take a quantitative a numerical approach
to this which is very very tempting for
many people you notice that lots of uh
thinkers are attracted to utilitarianism
in part because they think it's the best
theory so we have to ask these questions
how do we measure happiness or whatever
other value we are going to make Central
to our analysis now if it's money money
is pretty easy because it's you know how
much somebody's willing to pay for
something or how much something actually
does cost right but that's not usually
what we're working with and we
definitely wouldn't want to reduce all
values down to money would we so we need
to think in terms of like pain and
pleasure how do we in fact
quantify our own pains and Pleasures so
he says
um you know I'm going to leave aside
problems that must be solved if a
quantitative scales to be devised how
can we tell whether you get more
happiness from a rock song than you do
from hearing a Shakespeare sonnet well
read or for that matter Shakespeare
Sonnet you reading it or for that matter
you reading the lyrics to a rock song we
could go on and on and on how do you
tell whether you actually do in general
get more benefit from say eating a slice
of your favorite type of pie versus
having a cup of your favorite type of
soup and these are things that are sort
of within the same range how do you
measure losing your job versus
moving on to another position and
getting a different title all right how
do you actually quantify these matters
turns out it's not as easy as we might
at first think
then it gets more complicated
let's assume that you actually know your
psychology inside and out you can
quantify to you know whatever decimal
point exactly how much pleasure exactly
how much pain you get from each
experience and it remains consistent
over time
well how do you compare yourself
to other people the world is primarily
other people you're just one of many how
do we compare one other person to
another other person from ourselves I
mean we can pull them we can ask them
they may not actually know their own
psychology though he says here's an
example what about how much happiness
you get from a good salad at lunch
versus how much I get from one some
people are really into salad right
there's probably magazines and clubs out
there for people that are super super
into salad and they would of course get
a higher utility from a great salad and
you might actually get less because
salad isn't that Central to your life
similarly how much uh benefit in cost
benefit terms would you get from the
concert ticket that you purchased to
hear your favorite band compared to some
somebody else who just goes to all the
shows of whatever band happens to be
there it's it's difficult to quantify
this isn't it how do we compare and
contrast these against each other
now the third one is very important from
utilitarian perspective how can we in
fact calculate probabilities how can we
say what the actual numerical likelihood
of you enjoying or suffering pleasure or
pain cost or benefit will be for any
particular given thing so he gives an
example
how do we calculate the probability of a
given degree of Happiness we find in
seeing an old friend after many years I
mean is it 10 is it a hundred percent is
it
65.6 who knows right how do you
determine the probabilities for that
that's pretty tough it's a little bit
easier to say you know the probability
of me enjoying a
um
particular Shake made with a fruit that
I like like pineapple pretty high right
but they could screw it up and like he
points out the probability is not always
the same nor do we have a manageable
list of the relevant causative
variables so these seem to you know
present some obstacles for effectively
using cost benefit analysis don't they
but as Audi is going to point out to us
um any ethical theory that makes
beneficence doing good to other people
important is going to run into these
problems so it's not purely
utilitarianism or anything that's based
on cost-benefit analysis that's going to
run into this we could say that you know
Shakespeare not Shakespeare Cicero's
on duties which talks about Justice and
who we ought to do beneficence to that's
going to run into it as well even though
he has rules for that if we take
beneficence seriously we're bound to run
into these problems it just so happens
that utilitarianism because it values
Universal or general beneficence it
makes that absolutely Central to its
ethical Theory does run into these much
more quickly than other ethics okay so
you know maybe that gets utilitarianism
off the hook then he brings up two other
very interesting
objections and he says that
um suppose I promise you to do something
right I make a promise
do you want me calculating how much
unhappiness you or anyone else would
suffer if I don't perform versus how
much happiness I would get from breaking
my promise and doing something else
right and this is a constant Temptation
in life isn't it to say well I made a
commitment
but you know if I break that commitment
some people are going to be
bothered offended hurt but overall it's
gonna work out better right
well that's always a Temptation
particularly if you don't want to follow
through uh the obligation that you made
in making a promise and some people
actually do behave that way but we don't
want to reduce the morality of
commitments of fidelity of Promise
making simply to what is going to pay
off the best overall do we so this is a
very common concern or objection about
utilitarianism and then he also says
let's also ask whose happiness is in
question
um from utilitarian perspective we
cannot count one person as having more
valuable happiness than another so it
looks as if prosperous people and
prosperous nations may have to share
resources far more than most of them do
volunteer for more public and Foreign
Service doing this would be admirable
but on this Theory utilitarianism it
wouldn't just be admirable it would be
obligatory it would be what you have to
do
so this would seem to be a problem
because we typically want to in ethics
say there's the things that we are
morally required to do and then there
are the things that are good for us to
do and we're not necessarily morally
required in every situation to do them
maybe we're not morally required in any
situation but it would be good to do
those things right and utilitarianism
seems to be blurrying them together or
as Audi is going to say it assimilates
the obligatory to the laudable the
obligatory what we must do if we're to
be moral beings the laudatory what is
praiseworthy what is good but not
required for us to do and this seems to
be a problem as well and so he concludes
this by saying you know this is one
among other reasons we might prefer
other
approaches in ethics he will go on to
the conscient approach but he's also
going to consider a virtue ethics
approach coach and then his own
pluralistic ethics as well which he um
talks about near the end so these are
all alternatives to utilitarianism and
why would we turn to these Alternatives
because there's some problems with
taking a overall cost benefit analysis
approach to ethics in general as
utilitarianism does